Dopo il successo della scorsa puntata,
nella quale tentavamo di replicare la
carbonara francese e dopo l'odio che
abbiamo scatenato su internet e di cui
in parte ci pentiamo fortemente e
amaramente, è arrivato il momento di
viaggiare ancora una volta all'estero e
di tentare una ricetta facilissima e
prettamente italiana, che all'estero
riescono comunque a stuprare
Stiamo parlando della pizza con l'ananas.
Ciao ragazzi bentornati ad una puntata
di Cucina Buttata, è arrivato il momento
di allacciare nuovamente le cinture e
viaggiare oltreoceano per arrivare fino
in America, dove fanno questa roba, che è la
pizza con l'ananas. In molti la
conosciamo, è presente in un sacco di
meme, un sacco di persone la odiano e
fondamentalmente non piace a nessuno
se non a chi credo non abbia le papille
gustative, che sono un sacco di persone
in realtà all'interno del mondo, perché?
Perché la pizza con l'ananas sia alla base
proprio della controversia legata alla
pizza, cioè l'ananas non si mette sulla pizza
Ma siamo sicuri?
L'abbiamo mai provata? E' arrivato forse il
momento di assaggiarla? Assolutamente sì!
Ho paura? Pure. Iniziamo quindi con gli
ingredienti che servono per fare la
pizza con l'ananas. Prima di partire col
procedimento volevo dire solamente una
cosa, vi prego non generiamo odio, siamo
qui per divertirci. Ho cercato di
prendere proprio la ricetta più schifosa
della pizza con ananas, ce ne sono alcune
gourmet, ma io sono proprio andato nelle case
degli americani dove proprio il forno è
un optional ok? Quindi
Il Purci (Chef Rico)
CIao ragazzi (Purci)
Ciao Pier
Quindi sappiamo che la pizza con
l'ananas può piacere o può non piacere
famose una risata e continuiamo. Allora
per fare la pizza con l'ananas avremo
bisogno di ananas, prettamente
all'interno di un barattolo di latta
cioè non è che devi prendere il
frutto e aprirlo capito? Raccoglierlo
accudirlo e poi spellarlo vivo e
tagliarlo a rondelle. No, nel liquame
Cade così dalle piante. Poi
abbiamo bisogno della mozzarella quella
lì dura, quella lì che non butta fuori
nemmeno un pochino di latte, quella che
fa questo rumore cosa schiaffeggiate.
Prosciutto, una cipolla rossa
Vi dico solo che era insieme ad altre
sorelle che hanno iniziato a buttare del
liquame, quindi non so esattamente questa
cipolla che sapore abbia, ma non credo
che se farà schifo sarà colpa sua, e poi
abbiamo lui. In molti usano la salsa
marinara, qualcun'altro usa il ragù ma
abbiamo beccato alcune ricette di
persone che usano...il ketchup. Ora prima
che arrivino qua sotto i commenti tipo
"Mmm ma dai, che esagerato che sei!" Ragazzi io
ho visto una ragazzina mettere il
ketchup nelle penne lisce scotte, senza olio senza niente, avete presente quelle che mangi quando ti odi?
Ecco, lei aggiungeva...si odiava molto (Chef Rico)...si, lei non aveva una grande stima di se stessa
E infine abbiamo lei...i cani si comportano in modo strano (Chef Mario)...
I cani è vero stanno abbaiando. Hanno
iniziato ad abbagliare i cani "non farlo non farlo!"
Base fresca per la pizza,
sbam! All'estero sono in pochi a fare
tutto quanto il procedimento di
lievitazione e compagnia bella, hanno
queste specie di barattoli della
Pringles, che loro aprono e dentro ci
stanno, che ne so, la pasta per fare la
pizza, la pasta per fare i biscotti, la
pasta per qualsiasi cosa fanno co questi, pure secondo me infilarseli nel c**o. Prendiamo una bella teglia
della carta da forno
Te sempre un colpo di tosse eh? Da mesi, da mesi.
Scriviamo tutti quanti nell'Instagram di
Enrico "Guarisci presto" sotto la sua
ultima foto, che molto probabilmente sarà di sette
anni fa, del 2014, dove è appena uscito da scuola
Questa striscetta di pizza che non ci serve
la cuciniamo a bassa temperatura per farci
un bel cappio per impiccarci. Tac
Cosa devi fa con quest'altro pezzo di pizza? (Chef Rico)
Un fiore da mettere sulla nostra tomba
Iniziamo a bailare. Il nostro primo step è molto
simile a quello italiano, però non so
perché fa particolarmente male.
Scusate non ho il mio grembiule
Eh provvedi (Chef Rico)
Mmm diciamo mi sento più a mio agio.
Quindi ketchup
Ops
Basta basta (Chef Rico)
Deve esserci una bella base e poi l'odore del ketchup a me fa impazzire
l'idea che stia su una pizza mi fa
impazzire, nel senso che mi fa schifo. Scusami io so
che tu speraravi di essere una margherita,
ma non è stato il tuo giorno. Non tutti
vivono una vita felice cara pizza. Non mi
sta venendo già l'acquolina?
Io che cucino co sto grembiule e sta pizza
potremmo essere forse la cosa più
abominevole di questa giornata che vedrete sul web
No secondo me ci stanno tutti gli altri tuoi video (Chef RIco)
Prendiamo il prosciutto...uuu, bravo l'hai preso strong
Sapete cosa mi ricorda?L'odore del pan di spagna di
San Valentino. Madre santa! Ah no no, da vicino è
più buono. Ok ti fa solamente una
sorpresa all'inizio. E piazziamo il
prosciutto cotto che io di base non amo particolarmente
ma credo che sarà l'ultimo proprio dei
problemi
Lo metti in forno poi? (Chef Rico)
No nel cesso. Secondo voi se nascondo il ketchup
è come se non fosse mai esistito?
Tagliamo la mozzarella. Nostro cugino Pierfrancesco, che è quello che ci presta
la cucina del cugino di cucino, verrà
cacciato da tutte le persone che
sentiranno capito? Hai presente l'odore del
ragù quando torni a casa che dici
"Chi è che sta facendo i ragù?" L'odore del ciambellone "ma chi è che sta facendo il ciambellone?"
A lui entreranno e dirà "Chi è che sta facendo sta m***a?"
Guarda quanto latte esce
Così lo metti? Non lo tagli...? (Chef Rico)
E adesso è arrivato il momento.
L'occhio che ti guarda e io lo cieco
Ananas in liquame, stagno di ananas
Poi' molliccio, cioè è una cosa terribile terribile (Chef Rico)
Ieri ho chiesto a un ragazzo del supermercato
che ci lavorava dov'era questa roba e un
signore accanto mi fa "Tu ti vuoi fare male! (Chef Mario)
Menomale che non gli hai detto per cosa la volevi usare
sennò ti picchiava col bastone
Gli ho detto "Guardi è un esperimento" Lì ha capito?Ha pensato che era un c*****o
Speriamo che il forno faccia qualcosa (Chef Rico)
La bruci? Giusto per aggiungere quel
piccolo kick, quel calcio sulle gengive,
la cipolla rossa. A me comunque comunque ha fatto
più male fare la carbonara.
Perché ancora non te la sei magnata quella cosa (Chef Mario)
E loro la fanno bella spicchiosa
Ma non la fai a spicchi? (Chef Rico) No un minimo dai, poco poco la taglio
Cioè te stai a fa problemi per il taglio della cipolla dopo quello che hai fatto?( Chef Rico)
Lo so. guarda sto piangendo e non è per la cipolla
Se proprio ve la sentite buttatala in forno. 11 minuti
Arrivo pizza, quant' è che è stata alla fine? Quasi 15 minuti?
Dai che te la tiro fuori, spinga!
C'ha quasi un bell'aspetto guarda  eh (Chef Mario)
Non è un pò cruda? (Chef Rico) No è cotta. Perché è così molla? Gu è cruda
E' cruda! Adesso ragazzi è arrivato il momento
assaggiarla ma è molto calda
Meglio così che proprio ti brucia... (Chef Rico)
ti brucia tutto e non senti niente
Prendi un cucchiaio se vuoi bloccartela davanti, capito? (Chef Rico)
Così? Eh Grande! Sei sempre stato quello intelligente
dellla famiglia. Non è che ci vuole poco. Allora sono sempre stato quello stupido?
Potremmo far finta che siano patate. E' vero. L'aspetto è invitante eh. Però cioè se tutti demonizzano
un fondo di verità ci sarà! La mente
umana tende per preservarsi a voler
dimenticare gli shock e i traumi, quindi
noi continuiamo secondo me a dimenticare quello che
ci abbiamo messo dentro.
Guarda! Carina dai! E' arrivato il momento di assaggiarla
Ma che c***o c'entra?! Scusate venite ad assaggiare.
Non capisco se ho una fame becca
Non abbiamo pranzato
Ragazzi l'ananas non c'entra proprio un c***o
Il ketchup non è terribile, manco lo senti. Il ketchp non è così assurdo
Perché è l'ananas regà che copre tutto . No io non riesco più
ad assaggiare con l'ananas. Bisogna assaggiare
un pezzo senza ananas
Vabbé è un abominio anche senza
l'ananas comunque eh. Ragazzi io sto morendo di fame
Te la magni perché c'hai fame perché non se pò magnà sta roba. Regà senza ananas è solo ketchup
Questa pizza si commenta col silenzio.
Come avrete capito l'ananas non c'entra
niente. Guarda come se la sta a sfonnà quello (Chef Rico)
Cioè adesso ho fame e quindi avrei mangiato pure il tizzone ardente di
un caminetto acceso. Dai Gu chiudi questo video per noi (Chef Rico)
Lasciagliela al Purci. (Rico) Tra un po' quel frigo comincerà a muoversi. (Mario)
Tra un po' quel frigo comincerà a vomitare
Ok ragazzi questo qui era il mio tentativo,
mamma mia
era quella roba che tu mangiavi... pum! pugno.
Capito? A ogni a ogni morso. Dicevo siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video,
ragazzi fatemi sapere se avrete il
coraggio di provare questa ricetta. Non fatelo! (Mario) Se non in quesa vita in un'altra (Rico)
Qualora dovreste farlo fatemelo sapere taggandomi su Instagram, facendomi sapere anche se...che cosa?
hashtag ultimo respiro (Chef Rico)
Commentate qua sotto con hashtag ultimo
respiro ma soprattutto fatemi sapere se
avete mai mangiato la pizza con l'ananas
e se vi è piaciuta, cioè esiste qualcuno
al quale piace la pizza con l'ananas?
Ho sbagliato forse qualcosa io nel
procedimento?
A me sembra di aver seguito tutto quanto
in maniera abbastanza corretta. Come
sempre vi invito a iscrivervi a questo
canale, ad adattivicare, ad adattivicare? ...Ad
attivare la campanella qua sotto per
poter essere aggiornati ogni volta che
esce un nuovo video e soprattutto, come
sempre vi do di una buo... Mamma mia (Rico)
E come sempre vi do appuntamento alla prossima domenica con un altro video di
cucina, ciao. Ma non si dice piaccia? Hai
detto tipo...Oddio cos'hai detto! Hai deetto "Spero... (Mario)
vabbè se ho detto qualche
strafalcione ragazzi, come avete
capito sto un pochino incominciando a vedere annebbiato...Rutto